[Music]
what
well hello dear friends we're so glad
that you decided to tune in today to our
program I'd like to know as probably
many of you know this is a question and
answer program where you send us your
questions we do research and then we try
to answer the questions uh on the air so
that you can benefit from the answer to
your question uh why do we do it this
way you know there are uh some
Ministries that do live q&as uh we don't
do that because uh when a question is
asked many times there are is U much
material that we could use in answering
adequately the question but it doesn't
come to mind when the question Comes
live and so we would rather take the
questions online and do the research
find all of the evidence and then answer
the questions uh I'd like to give you
the address where you can send us your
questions it's an electronic address
it'll be on the screen TVM tv.org once
again
TVM tv.org we would be delighted to
receive your questions also we want to
ask you to continue praying for Secrets
unsealed and some TV uh we do many
programs here we do cooking demos Health
lectures children's programs musical
prog programs of course lots of sermons
and um we appreciate your prayers as we
do those programs also we appreciate
your financial support if you are able
please help us financially so that we
can continue our work of taking quality
programming to uh the world Amen and I
have with me uh Pastor David Salasar uh
in charge of our Hispanic uh
broadcasting and production here at
Secrets unsealed it's always good to
have you with us Pastor thank you Pastor
bour is always a blessing for me to stay
with you here in this program one of the
favorite programs for sure to answer
questions and to be able to study
together and prepare for uh these
questions that are really sometimes very
important very insightful some of them
really let us know uh how much they have
been blessed by the programs as well and
is is always a blessing to interact with
our audience in a way amen praise the
lord well never should we open the word
without prayer absolutely or discuss
Bible topic topics without prayer right
and so as we begin we do need to have a
word of prayer and I'd like to ask you
to please pray absolutely let us pray
our gracious Heavenly Father we are once
again coming before you today to seek
your uh presence in our minds to seek
the power of the Holy Spirit to lead us
into all truth and you have promised
that when we humbly commit commit to you
and ask uh of you the knowledge of your
word that you will help us to increase
in faith
and to understand the scriptures and
know the power that you have for in them
to us we ask now that you will help us
to uh give a good answer that the answer
may bring someone closer to you and that
they may again be uh led to the truth in
Christ Jesus we pray in Jesus name amen
amen all right the first question is
more of a
comment uh several years ago I did a
series uh titled believe His prophets
prophetic guidance in the Advent
movement uh it was actually I think an
anchor School of Theology that we did
entirely on the spirit of Prophecy and
it was a great blessing uh we had it
here in the studio we had a good group
of people here and we studied various
aspects of the life and Ministry of
Ellen White and in one of those uh
presentations lesson number three
specifically prophets and time
prophecies I me mentioned that the
message that Jeremiah gave was not
present Truth for the time in which he
lived and uh basically I was talking
about the 70-year prophecy that began in
605 and ends in 536 my point there was
that Jeremiah was not alive in the year
536 when that 70-year prophecy became
present truth because it becomes present
truth when it ends not when it begins
exactly uh so that was my emphasis uh we
don't have a specific date uh set in
stone of when Jeremiah died right I
might have insinuated that he was alive
uh you know when uh the prophecy was
given and when the Captivity began that
wasn't the impression that I wanted to
leave I wanted to leave the uh the
impression that that message that
Jeremiah gave of the 70-year prophecy
became present Truth for the generation
that lived when the time period came to
an end sense so probably I could have
expressed it a little
more specifically yeah uh but uh I
wanted to make that clarification uh so
basically that thank you for sending
that uh keeps me on my toes exactly and
make sure that I say things the way that
they're supposed to be said so thank you
so much for U making that
clarification uh the next question is I
know in heaven we won't see our beloved
pets well what Bible verse does that
come
from I assume that probably uh this
person is right it's Beth right it
doesn't say where she's writing from
yeah but is it wrong to pray to ask God
to help them while on
Earth it's if they need medical
intervention Etc um I don't find any
Prohibition in the Bible that forbids
you praying for your pets in fact I know
children that pray for their pets the
Lord I think the Lord understands right
I mean it's pets are are under our care
you know and just not pets that we you
know have but for in the in the Jewish
community in the Jewish culture when the
lord gave them the indications to become
a nation you know they were to take care
of their animals very carefully and they
were to be careful with them give give
them bre don't abuse them don't take you
know you know advantage of them and so
God does give us an indication in the
word of God to be careful with animals
those that are under our care even
though they are beasts they are not
intelligent beings like we are
necessarily you know they don't have a
soul or nothing like that or they don't
you know they're not going to be redeem
Christ did not come to redeem animals
although he came to redeem Earth and
human beings still pets are under our
care and animals under care we need to
be care be be mindful of them and I
don't see anything wrong for praying
that God will help them you know give
them healing when we see them you know
and I think that's that's very important
um you know he Christ even said you know
if he takes care of he sees the sparrow
you know he takes care of them you know
he will care take care of you but it
shows the care that God has for every
one of his creatures you know yeah and
pets are members of the family I mean uh
for many many years we had four
cats and uh now we have two uhhuh one
one of them is uh she's a six-toed cat
wow you know most of those cats are from
uh Key West down in Florida yeah and uh
they they're unusual and she is most of
the time hiding you know you most people
will never see her uh we see her because
she's gotten used to us and another uh
side we have one called Harry and uh we
call him Dirty Harry because he rolls
around in the dirt and uh he is so
friendly you know you're laying on the
couch he'll come in rub his nose against
your nose you know and they become
members of the family you fall in love
with your pets yeah so I can understand
why children would would pay pray for
their pets I don't think that there's
any uh Prohibition in the Bible for that
even though they don't have freedom of
choice you know if they bite you they're
not going to suffer the Judgment or
anything like that right uh so you know
I I we don't have a thus sayith the Lord
but I don't think that it causes any
damage no I don't think so and yeah the
principles is you know the word of God
is take care of those things that are in
your care in your possession amen and
that includes asking God to you know
bless them and heal heal them if needed
so yes I might mention a book that was
written by Steve Walberg of White Horse
media MH I think the title of the book
is will my pet be in heaven and I would
recommend that you contact white white
horse media and uh and you get a copy of
that book it's a real nice book uh
children can understand it uh so once
again it's Steve Walberg uh White Horse
media and I believe the title of the
book is will my pet be in heaven
interesting reading because I know lots
of kids that would love to have their
pets in heaven yeah know and kids and
old too Pastor you know young and old we
all love
pets so all right well let's go to the
next question it comes from Brother
t uh it doesn't said uh it says do not
read
email okay so how are you going to
answer the question if we don't read the
email yeah no I think it means you know
uh you know not necessarily disclose the
his email address or who that person is
okay so so what is the gist of the
question I mean the question
you know it's um he this person is
having issues with someone living in the
same neighborhood or in the same
building it seems there's some tenants
the owner of the property is an
Adventist person it's one that you know
uh owns the whole building and
the people that are I'm assuming their
Apartments I'm not even clearly sure how
that works but there must be some
neighbors who are not Adventists who are
tenants and and they are breaking the
Sabbath and the question is
should the owner who is an
Adventist tell them to respect you know
Sabbath and not to I guess maybe put the
loud music I don't exactly know it
doesn't really tells exactly the issues
but there's just situations happening
there that are conflicting you know
between Adventist and the non-adventist
and um the owner of the properties so
should the owner of the Adventist kind
of enforce if you will or tell them that
they should not break the Sabbath um so
the question is that pastors that's the
gist of it okay so uh there is uh
something in the fourth Commandment that
provides a
principle uh let's read the fourth
Commandment Exodus 20:8 remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days you
shall labor and do all your work but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of the Lord
your God in it you shall do no work you
nor your son nor your daughter nor your
male servant nor your female servant nor
your cattle nor your stranger who is
within your Gates M um now this problem
can be resolved I think quite easily if
you include this in the
lease you know if they're tenants yeah
which means that they're renting mhm the
rooms right then it needs to be made
clear in the lease about the Sabbath and
behavior that is acceptable or not
acceptable on the Sabbath yeah in those
common areas probably you know yeah yeah
so so if you include it in the lease uh
then you know you have some basis for
telling them that they need to tone it
down or they need to keep their their
celebration private right right so I
think that that passor right I think
that sometimes uh we have to also be
careful not to uh Force somebody's
conscience into obeying you know we have
to make them make the choice as you
mentioned if the lease has something
there where it says look you know we
believe in the Santi of the Sabbath day
and you know we then that person can
make the choice of okay I'll I'll accept
these conditions and I'll move in but if
you now want to implement anything not
written you are probably better off just
praying and saying Lord help me to show
a loving attitud to let help me win them
over with goodness with kindness and
perhaps that's the way now you know I
think that it's is important you right
now cannot make somebody choose to do
the right thing if they haven't um had
the you know warning beforehand so I
think you have to also be careful not to
force upon somebody else your beliefs
you can't do that either and you cannot
require tenants uh to abide by something
that is not in the lease exactly you
know it needs to be made clear yes okay
so now let's go to our next uh
question uh this is uh once again it
says do not read
email no I I guess is we need to keep
that person Anonymous that's what it
means yeah but the gist the gist of it
has to do with with whether it's okay to
drink uh uh fermented wine now and then
yeah
is it a matter of Salvation whether you
eat unclean Foods unclean meats or not
um you know and then that brings to view
what the food that is brought to the
potluck you know sometimes there's food
that is not healthy that is brought to
the potlock uh are all these salvation
issues that that's the main question
yeah the main question are the Salvation
issues well you know we have often come
to these type of discussions
with many people and uh even sadly and I
say sadly because uh you
know I would expect people that are in
leadership positions in the church some
ministers in the church should be the
ones to set an example of of how to to
live and and and to not only set an
example but be really uh willing to to
uphold the highest
standard if you will in their in their
experience but sometimes I've met
several people who have said you know
there's things about eating or drinking
they're not salvational they're not you
know what makes us save or lost and with
that argument basically they can eat and
drink whatever they want but I feel this
way um salvation you know who defines
what's salvational and what's not
salvational I think sometimes we go into
these this you know ideas and I feel
that if we just come have a attitude of
humility before the Lord if the Lord
reveals something it's because it helps
us in our walk with him it enables us to
come closer to him and he knows best
what really is for benefit rejecting
light of the word of God light in how
we're to live how we're to conduct
ourselves how we're to participate on
food or or or drinking it's actually
going against the Lord's will so will it
affect you you know Paul speaks of our
bodies being the Temple of the Holy
Spirit and that whatever we are to put
into our bodies affects our spiritual
relationship therefore if the Lord has
says clearly what is the type of food
that we should not be
eating uh you know specifically you know
he has given us first he gave us the
diet in Genesis a very clear diet of
simple fruits and you know nuts and and
and things of of the of the plant
kingdom and then he allowed as time went
on to eat certain animals as as a as a
option now was that his plan originally
no will that be the plan in heaven we're
not going to be eating no meat in heaven
Pastor you know there's going to be no
killing you know animals so God is now
trying to bring us back to the original
state to be translated to so if the Lord
is revealing to us an prophecy very
clearly indications that food affects us
food affects our bodies that there are
things that we should completely avoid
uh why are we now thinking God doesn't
really know what's best he just says
things that we don't really need to take
care of or pay attention to so I believe
that the spirit of rebellion is the one
that considers things like this and says
you know it's not solutional I don't
want to pay attention to that you know
the Bible uh speaks to us in principles
M the Bible doesn't give a list of all
the foods in the supermarket that you
can eat and all of the foods in the
supermarket that you can't eat right the
Bible gives us a principle for example
one of those principles is in uh 1
Corinthians 3 do you not know that you
are the temple of God and that the
spirit of God dwells in you if anyone
defiles the temple of God God will
destroy him for the temple of God is
Holy which Temple you are and then uh
also chapter 6 19 and 20 or do you not
know that your body is the Temple of the
Holy Spirit who is in you whom you have
from God and you are not your own for
you were bought at a price therefore
glorify God in your body and in your
spirit which are Gods MH so those are
principles mhm which means that every
anything that is harmful right to our
health is a
violation of the temple of God right
which is the body and the spirit which
represents our spiritual nature uh you
know some people are what I call minimal
Christians they want to do the minimum
for Christ yeah but we should we should
go the maximum yes you know some people
say well you know wine is a great
antioxidant they they're that say that
you know it helps you prevent heart
attacks right but it's not the
fermentation that does that exactly it's
the grape juice that's right so just
have grape juice and you know there's
always
dangers when you start drinking
fermented um wine there's always the
danger that you're going to take an
additional step and you're going to go
too far yeah you're going to get drunk
and the Bible has clear counselors wine
is a mocker strong drink is r aging it
says in Proverbs
20:1 chapter 31 says that it's not for
Kings to drink intoxicating drink or
wine because because they can't think
straight you have the example of naab
and Abu you know they had too much to
drink they were not able to distinguish
between the holy and the common right
and so why be borderline Christians and
say how far can I go yeah and still be a
Christian and still be an Adventist go
all the way
you know abstain from intoxicated drink
there's plenty of other stuff to drink
there's a pomegranate juice there's
grape juice there's orange juice there's
all different kinds of of juices that
can be drunk where you don't have to uh
don't have fermentation that can you
know actually affect your thinking
processes the same with unclean Meats
why would you want to eat unclean Meats
if you're an Adventist yeah I mean why
would you set want to set a pork chop if
God has conversed has has uh actually um
you know
cursed that animal as food why would you
why would you want to go right to the
edge and say well you know it doesn't
really hurt me uh physically when it
really does absolutely don't be a
minimal Christian don't be a borderline
Christian go all the way and be a full
Christian amen and you know Pastor I
remember hearing from a uh very nice you
know person that that speaks about
health um he was mentioning that often
times we are trying to like you
mentioned try to be so close to the
Border you know instead of being away
from the the line of uh of Divisions
between a Christian and non-Christian we
want to be so much in the border that
it's so easy to go to the other side
continually um for example he said you
know when the lord gave
the strict orders about eating animals
he mentioned a very specific thing about
animals you know he said do not take
part of the blood in the in the meal in
the
meat and as we know scientifically the
you know the blood carries all the
things the nutrients and also the toxins
everything goes through that so you know
God knew that it was important for men
to avoid any blood while they eat meat
you know um but today people they say oh
uh steak is a clean animal so I'm going
to just eat it as it comes full of blood
all of that and God even said that that
was Abomination so you know he was
saying it's sad that we have entered
into this aspect of following the word
of God halfway and we Delight in these
foods that are
really studies scientists are showing
clearly that they are not the best type
of meals for our bodies our bodies need
uh better things to be taken and there's
a huge push in the world now for more of
a ve vegan or vegetarian diet than
before because there's a need really for
our own species to be able to survive
and to grow even healthier by leaving
away certain meals that are from animal
sources so if God has revealed through
his her through her Pro through his
Prophet through the spirit prophecy
clearly
that today is best if we abstain from
certain things uh I believe that if we
go contrary to that we are only putting
our hearts in Rebellion to the word of
God and how can God reveal to us clearer
things if we are not willing to submit
to certain principles that are very
clear and more uh I guess Advanced or
more clearly distinct through the spirit
prophecy so you know it's interesting
how the Christian world
uh emphasizes the importance of uh doing
the minimum for the Lord uh you know
they say oh no the Sabbath that was
nailed to the cross yes and uh all the
health flws that was nailed to the cross
all the ceremonial laws those were
nailed to the cross yeah so anything
that requires any sacrifice anything
that requires submitting our perverted
tastes is relegated to the Old Testament
yeah and many say you know the the
prescriptions about the animals that you
can eat and the the ones that you can't
eat that was part of the ceremonial law
not so it has nothing to do with the
priesthood it has nothing to do with the
ceremonies of the temple in fact in
Leviticus 11 where you have one of the
two lists of animals that can be eaten
and animals that cannot be eaten uh says
now the this is Leviticus 11 verse1 now
the Lord spoke to Moses and Aaron saying
to them speak to the children of Israel
mhm not the priests the children of
Israel saying these are the animals
which uh which you may eat among all the
animals that are on the earth among the
animals and then comes all the
prescription of the the kinds of animals
that they can eat um now I would say
that it's not safe to eat those animals
even now the ones that are allowed by
the Lord yeah because the the world is a
lot sicker you know and they inject
hormones in the animals so they grow
faster yeah they they they uh you know
the diseases have proliferated in the
animal kingdom so what was safe even in
biblical times yeah isn't safe now so
that's why Ellen White states she says
it's better to abstain totally and
completely from flesh food even from the
so-called clean flesh Foods right is is
she contradicting the Bible because the
Bible says you can eat them and she says
don't eat them now no because the
circumstances have changed see when the
circumstances change God's counsel
changes in the past you know they would
drain all of the blood out of the meat
right the meat was a lot healthier than
it is now yeah so if if things change
God is going to change his counsel right
what would you think of a God who said
uh you know I said that could eat all
these kinds of Flesh and I don't change
so even if they cause cancer and they're
sick now tough luck I said they could
eat it what kind of God would be that
yeah he changes his counsel in honor
with his character and in honor with the
circumstances I know pastor and this is
the thing you know he as you mentioned
he he gives us a a a real clear
indication of what he sees okay also in
according to circumstances the fact is
that he allowed people to eat meat
uh After the flood after the fact that
there was a necessity for to sustain
life as a necessity not as a not because
the diet originally was wrong it
actually was perfect you know it was a
perfect diet but because of the fact
that the Earth had gone through a flood
had gone through this experience and to
in a sense also limit the lifespan of
mankind he gave them meat uh but is the
the original plan was something else and
we need to go back to the original plan
to the original plan of Genesis no plan
B yes plan a amen it's the best you know
a vegan diet obviously is the best diet
that we can have to uh keep our good
health good stamina good strength yeah
and clear thinking amen Amen to that
well time has flown by again uh thank
you so much for joining us in this
program I'd like to know we want to
encourage you to send your questions to
us TVM tv.org we hope to see you next
time the Lord bless you and keep you in
his care is our
[Music]
prayer